hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll human
beings have a capacity for reasoning and
I don't mean that in contrast with other
animals or anything like that at least
not right now we're not trying to figure
out where we stand and the evolution of
life or the hierarchy or anything like
that but some of us like to think that
we can actually reason about things
sometimes I don't even mean rationality
rationality is sort of a particular kind
of reason there's different ways in
which we reason about the world so where
did that capacity come from what is it
how does it work how do we make it
better this is something we've talked
about on the podcast before and it's a
topic of great current interest people
falling prey to misinformation to
cognitive biases to conspiracy theories
and so forth how does all that work at a
deep cognitive science level so today's
guest Hugo Mercier is a French cognitive
scientist uh he's done a lot of work and
he's written two wonderful books I can
highly recommend one with Dan sperber is
called the Enigma of reason and that's
literally about how reason came to be
both as a philosophical question but
also scientifically back there in the
origin of human beings when did we start
using reason to think about things
carefully rather than just acting in a
if this then that simple kind of way and
one of their main arguments one of their
main points is that reason evolved in
order to give reasons for things now
that sounds kind of maybe tautological
but the point is to give reasons in
other words a social function not just
you by yourself or your ancestor by
yourself in isolation thinking about the
world and solving puzzles but in order
to convince other people to do what we
wanted them to do you know one of the
big breakthroughs in human social
cognition is the ability to work
together to make an agreement if I do
this now you'll do this tomorrow right
this greatly enabled human beings to
cooperate and to build things greater
than themselves so sometimes you can get
other people to do what you want just by
threatening them but other times you're
going to want to offer a reason right do
this because of this reason trust me for
the following reasons and so Hugo and
Dan sperber argue that the reason why we
invented reason is to give reasons why
to other people it is more recent book
called not born yesterday Hugo makes a
very interesting point about our
gullibility and our skepticism you know
that among people who care a lot about
rationality and getting the right answer
the idea of being skeptical of crackpot
theories is a very very big one a very
very important one makes sense to me to
be skeptical of crackpot theories but
Hugo's point is that if anything
the usual human failure is on the other
side of being too skeptical but the
point is we're skeptical of the wrong
things we are actually being skeptical
of all the enormous piles of information
telling us not to believe that kooky
Spirit conspiracy theory so rather than
being more skeptical of the crazy
theories being more open and honestly
evaluating all the potentially contrary
information that comes in there's a lot
going on here you know reason is a
complicated thing and both how it
evolved over time how it's working in
our brains right now and how we can make
it better these are important questions
it's a very mindscaping kind of
conversation let me occasionally remind
you as always that you can become a
patreon supporter of mindscape you can
go to patreon.com Sean M Carroll uh
pledge a dollar whatever per episode and
that helps keep us going it uh helps pay
for things like transcriptions of every
single episode that you can find on the
main website
preposterousuniverse.com podcast and
patreon supporters get ad-free versions
of the podcast and can ask questions for
the ask me anything episodes so use your
reason give a good reason why you should
join the patreon and with that let's go
[Music]
thank you
Mercier welcome to the mindscape podcast
thank you for having me so we're talking
about reason and obviously that's a big
topic and we'll get into what is
precisely meant by that in detail but I
bet that given previous things we've
talked about in the podcast a lot of
people will conflate it with rationality
right away I know I sometimes do that
but I think I think you don't want us to
do that right away so maybe I'll give
you a chance to tell us what we should
be thinking about when we talk about
reason
so you know there's this thing that for
psychologist theories I like
toothbrushes you know everybody has
their own and no one wants to use
anybody else's and so we have we're a
field that has a bit of trouble
sometimes agreeing on uneven basic terms
so what I'm going to tell now is is kind
of my or ours with dance program Mike
corther on that work on reason
um definition of what we think reason is
and according to us reason is both uh
the reasons we give each other so when I
try to convince you um to do something
or to believe something I will give you
reasons that you will evaluate
and reason is also the cognitive
mechanisms that allow us to produce and
to evaluate these reasons so it's very
specific
um and most of the Mind goes on without
using reasons at all so when you
perceive things when you engage in kind
of much our behavior when you act in the
world when you draw a lot of inferences
we know I'm looking at you I can infer
things about you know whether you're
healthy or not what you're thinking etc
etc all of that
we do we believe without using reason so
reason reason is quite specific in our
in our framework
so in other words just to be super duper
clear here uh
reason doesn't mean being logical or
being rational
no so for instance you know you can
think that most animals are rational in
most of the behaviors that they engage
in
um and according to us they don't use
reason to do that they they have a host
of other cognitive mechanisms that
function very well
um but they don't use reason and and yet
they're rational moreover
um in many of the ways in which uh
humans use reason they would they
wouldn't really be qualified as rational
uh in most kind of normative models so
people can use reasons to engage in
motivated reasoning to justify
conclusions that they already believed
uh to kind of delude themselves into
believing something so I think the two
of them are quite separate good okay
that does make a lot of sense so and
again just to let the audience in on the
background that we're talking about here
um you mentioned we're talking right now
about your the the book Enigma of reason
you have a new book out uh on
um not born yesterday about how we're
less gullible than you think we'll get
there at some point I don't want you to
feel bad but
um in the Enigma of reason you do
remind us that there is this uh not
maybe not a consensus but a feeling
among a lot of people that there are
dual process models of how we think in
the brain and and you think that a dual
process two processes aren't quite
enough uh so maybe remind us what the
Dual process model is uh that we're
fighting against so the drill process
model which has been not developed
really but at least popularized by by
Danny kaneman most famously
um holes that you can divide most
cognitive like kind of mental mechanisms
in two types one is kind of intuitive
mechanisms so then again you see someone
immediately you can infer how old they
are or their gender you know their mood
maybe what you know where they're
looking etc etc and you do that
effortlessly you do that unconsciously
and the conclusion you know that person
is angry for instance just kind of pops
into your mind without really new you
knowing uh you know how it got there by
contrast the system to processes would
be things that would be more kind of
more cautious more careful uh more
explicit so when you're next holding a
Sudoku problem maybe when you're doing
you know mathematics you're taking your
time it's a Ford fool it's demanding
it's conscious and so I think this entry
this this dichotomy
is quite intuitive and that's partly I
think why why it is um successful
and maybe though it I'll I'll confess
I'm in in the back of my mind I just
have been talking to Daniel Dennett for
several days has he been visiting Johns
Hopkins and so all of his thoughts are
are talking to me in the back of my mind
great thoughts uh it's almost like a
little homunculus model because that
system two the cognitive part is is
rational all by itself in some ways yes
that is one of the big problems with
this thing is that in a way we think
well okay so system one is the stuff I
don't control but there is as you're
saying this little these little
homunculus this little person inside me
who is system two
but then obviously as kind of cognitive
scientists our tasks would be to explain
what that is like you know we can't you
can't have you know you don't Solve the
Riddle of how people act by assuming
that there is a little person inside
their head that's just you know pushing
the problem further
um so you know I completely agree with
that criticism here and so the obvious
thing if we're going to critique a dual
process model is to say we need a triple
or quadruple process model I mean what
is the direction we should be moving in
here so yeah I think so at our time I I
guess I'm an evolutionary psychologist
and one of the insights of of
evolutionary psychology is that uh the
human mind uh exactly as as much as
other any other organ or any like a cell
or even any complex artifact or complex
piece of code is made of of countless
mechanisms that work in in relative
isolation from each other so for
instance for you know you or your
listeners who've had any experience
building something complex or writing a
piece of of computer code if you just
write when big thing is that good
Network you need to have modules and
each of them is going to accomplish a
specific function that way if something
breaks down you can figure out what's
going on uh you know it's it's just
that's the way anything that's complex
or you know you men sell with the
mitochondria and the nucleus anything
that's complex is modular to a very high
degree and so we believe that the mind
uh this is also true of the human mind
so you have you know mechanisms
dedicated to Vision mechanisms and
Within These mechanisms you know
mechanisms dedicated to perceiving you
know simple shapes and assembling them
together Etc et cetera so we have a
myriad of mechanisms uh that work then
again in relative isolation with each
other obviously they communicate with
each other they send information to each
other
but they are still relatively impervious
to what's happening in the rest of the
brain otherwise it would just be a giant
mess and nothing would get done
and so there is not just one sort of
rationality module there's many
different modules and rationality
somehow emerges out of a multiplicity of
interactions yes exactly yeah so you
know if you look at animal any kind of
cognitively complex animal will have
mechanisms dedicated to perception to
matter Behavior to you know to to
finding a good mate to uh you know to to
competing against against uh against you
know other individuals from the same
species to supporting Predators etc etc
and all of these mechanisms will have to
be coordinated like the animal has to be
able to make decisions whether this is
mate on one side and food on the other
they have to decide these sort of things
but but each mechanism is still
relatively uh independent of the others
but there is some level at which Things
become conscious or we become
consciously aware of them right I mean
is that to what extent how should I be
thinking about the role of Consciousness
or awareness in this picture
so it's it's not something that's that
I've really given enough thought I guess
so I don't have a super smart answer to
give you you know then the net will be a
much better person to talk to like that
um for us I guess what matters is that
uh we happen to be conscious of most of
what we reason about so if we if we use
reason in the way that we use the term
as this mechanism that allows us to to
produce and to evaluate evaluate reasons
we happen to be conscious of that all
the time so not in that we're always
conscious of that but whenever we do
reason we are we are conscious of it
um
and so that's one of the of the traits
that I think make us
equate uh reason with system two because
you know that's the thing that we know
goes on in our mind because we have
access to it we can report it to others
whereas the vast majority like the you
know the the proverbial hidden part of
the iceberg goes on all the time
unconsciously and that also actually
makes tend to make people forget that
even when it comes to reason a lot of it
is unconscious so you know if I if I
think of a reason for to convince you of
something I don't know how I found it
it's just kind of pops into my head when
I give you a reason instantaneously you
have any nutrition about whether it's a
good or a bad reason you don't know why
that's the case it just pops into your
head so even if something in something
like reason that has that is quite
explicit there is also a you know a
cognitive layer that's that's you know
kind of basically inaccessible to
consciousness
good
um
yeah okay so it's certainly very very
good lesson that a lot of what we come
to believe through what we think of as
reasoning and reflection is uh uh a
result of a lot of things going on below
the surface that we're completely
unaware of yeah it has to be the case I
mean you know otherwise you have this
kind of infinite regress like you know
you have to have a reason for your
reason for your reasons at some point we
just have intuitions and and there is
some some you know cognitive processes
that in the future people will be able
to explain but they have to be there you
know things don't happen just by Magic
and there is something about human
beings and the way that they reason that
is maybe a little bit special here
well according to us we're actually the
only ones to reason at all so um other
um other animals engage in a lot of
complex thoughts and they can they can
do a lot of you know wondrous things
with their with their minds with this
ability we have of producing and
evaluating reasons is something that as
far as we can tell no other animal has
in part because it really it requires a
complex system of communication to be
able to express these these thoughts
these reasons
um
and so and so yeah other animals go on
you know completely fine without reason
which then raises the question of you
know why do we have it like it seems you
know we kind of take it for granted well
you know it sounds like a great idea uh
but you know your dog or you know any
wild animal does you know perfectly fine
uh without uh without reasoning at all
and and so why do we bother
good and I I hope you can answer that
question before uh at some point but but
this is helping me figure out what to
emphasize and things you've already said
so you've already said this but um you
know dogs and and animals think and they
can even solve puzzles but you're saying
that they don't do what you are calling
reasoning and there's a linguistic uh
barrier here because
you're you're raising the importance of
the idea of coming up with reasons as
something that reasoning does so maybe
amplify that a little bit yes no exactly
I mean
as I was saying for us reason is really
the ability that we have of producing
reasons and it's not it's not something
that we can take for granted at all so
for instance then again if you're a
computer programmer
um you write a piece of code that works
perfectly well the piece of code is not
going to be able by default to explain
to you why it's making these decisions
you know so you write a good and he
tells you well or you feel like in your
chat TPT you know this is the output
but then it's a it's a black box if you
want your code to be able to explain to
someone why it has come up with that
decision you need to write another piece
of code
that will somehow figure out well
actually that decision I made because of
this and I can I can spell that out and
I can tell someone that and so the same
would be true for humans so other
animals they have this very very complex
uh piece of codes or the equivalent
neuronal equivalent in in their brains
and they function perfectly well but if
someone you know if you ask your dog you
know but why did you do this which we
sometimes do I guess the dog is not
gonna it will give you a very
informative answer and and for you know
everybody if she has that to someone
they will tell you something there will
be more or less informative
but in order to do that you need a
different piece of software that will
look into your own mind and look into
your decisions and your behavior and try
to give you a reason for why you believe
something or why you did something and
it doesn't come you know kind of
pre-packaged with the rest of their mind
like you need a different piece of
software that only does that and so the
question is why do we why are we able to
do this so it's really that meta level
that uh ability to talk about why we're
doing things and to offer reasons that's
what you're saying is a little bit
different in humans than in other
animals my my cat is very good at
opening drawers but he will not tell me
why he's opening this nope actually has
very very good reasons but um yes and
any indeed I mean we we really take it
for granted in humans but uh but we
don't expect it of any other any I mean
sometimes we ask them why they do things
but it's obviously that we don't expect
that sir and and from that perspective
it makes perfect sense that language is
closely connected to this right the
offering up of reasons is something that
sounds like it requires a language is
there a chicken and egg problem about
which comes first reasoning or language
so we believe that
um for a reason to have evolved for for
it to have made sense that reason would
evolve people our ancestors would
already have had a relatively complex
Communication in place
so you know as you were saying we have
this theory about why reason evolved
that you know I'll I'll delve into later
um
and it just first it doesn't make sense
that we people would have or any other
animal would have reason if they don't
already communicate
uh that being said though what's really
crucial is not language language per se
but more the ability to understand what
people mean more generally so I can give
you a Reason by pointing for instance
because you know but why do you think
that and there's something in our
environment that clearly explains why
you think that I can just point to it
and that's gonna you know that's gonna
that's going to to do the job of
explaining to you well I believe that
you know it's like you know why do you
think that Johnny is here I can just
point to John and and so I don't need
language to do that but I need the
ability to express my thoughts in a way
that you will understand it and and you
need the ability to to to uh decode so
to speak that
okay but now I guess I'm a little
confused because I was gonna I was gonna
happily think that language came along
and then we we bootstrapped from there
to inventing reasoning and and the
appeal to reasons but I think animals
can also point at things right
uh that's a good point actually they
they
in some cases some quite a lot of
species in particular domesticated
species understand pointing
um interestingly chimpanzees they can in
some very rare context but in most
contexts they don't
okay so for instance if you take a chimp
and there's two buckets two are back
buckets and they know that there is food
under one of the buckets and you point
to the bucket that has the food they
won't pick it then they'll they'll be a
chance by contrast if you try grabbing
one of the buckets they will know that's
where the food is okay that's because
they don't assume that you want to help
them they're they live in a very
competitive world and so you know
they're smart they know that if you want
to pick that bucket it's the one with
the food but pointing implies that I'm
just going to help you get at the food
and it's not something that chimpanzees
do to each other a whole lot so in some
contexts with some individuals who know
each other and they can get pointing but
they usually don't understand it but oh
like a goat will understand pointing by
human because Goods have a long history
of interacting with humans and of humans
being kind of nice to them because you
know the goods they're you know they're
hurting them
and so it's not it's not a matter of
General cognitive ability it's more a
matter of the relationship that these
animals have had with humans or with
each other other kind of evolutionary
time
but even if they could point and
sometimes is raised that have been
raised by humans at two point to some
extent
um that no other animal has the human
ability to express meanings uh through
either words or you know gestures or any
other mean and to understand what other
people mean in that way in this very
kind of flexible open-ended manner so
they have you know many like animal
communication is fascinating and
endlessly complex but it's pretty
specific we have kind of one signal to
mean one thing they don't have this kind
of General mechanism for for uh
communicating meaning that humans have
so when an animal is pointing or when
we're pointing and they understand it it
doesn't represent the offering of a
reason like it might for a human being
no no it represents at best you know
they're going to to get some some very
basic information out of it like you
know where some food might be got it
okay uh we would say anyway I mean
someone could try to prove us wrong that
they would not understand pointing uh in
the context of offering a reason yeah
okay so good so now we can turn to this
question of why it's so important I mean
and I think as you say in the book
there's a double-edged question
um why do we have reason and then if
it's so good why doesn't everyone else
have reason like why doesn't it spread
more quickly yeah no exactly so you need
to have a story or a theory
that Bruce explains why we have it and
you know when we need it to have it
because like you know I was talking
about a piece of software but it's a you
know it's a piece of your brain
somewhere some neurons that are
dedicated to the task of finding and
evoluting reasons and neurons take a lot
of energy to grow and and some energy to
maintain
so there has to have been selection
pressures that meant that a manga
ancestors those that had a better
ability to reason uh manage to kind of
outcompete uh even if slightly uh other
other individuals
and then if we have a good reason for
why humans have risen then why you know
why only us
um
and so the theory we have is
that if you what characterizes humans
um by contrast with other primates at
least is their ability as we're saying
to cooperate with each other and to
communicate with each other
and that is something we do to an extent
that is really unprecedented among
primates where you know many primates
have some Communication System they
cooperate to some extent with each other
but nothing like like what humans are
able to do is like a whole really
different ballpark
and in that context when you start
communicating with each other and
cooperating with each other
that creates we believe the right
environment for reason to evolve and
that can attribute to to explanations
really there
when is uh when you cooperate with
people it's really important for you to
judge them because you want to make sure
that the people you cooperate with are
nice that they're you know they're going
to reciprocate that they are competent
they know what they're doing
and uh and the problem is that judging
people if you don't have access to their
minds is really hard because you might
do something and you mean well but you
know you mess up and so I may think oh
you're clumsy or you know maybe you're a
bad person when in fact you meant really
well
so if you can explain to me let's say
you do something that appears maybe a
bit mean but then you explain to me that
you meant well then I can correct uh the
way I perceive you in a way that's both
good for you because you know you
protect your reputation and good for me
because I don't think probably of you
when it was not justified
and so
when people cooperate it becomes super
useful to be able to justify themselves
to give reasons for why they do the
things they do so that others can
understand them and can and can judge
them can accurately
so so we believe that Swan of the of the
pressures that led to the emergence of
reason and indeed in our everyday lives
we do that constantly so whenever you do
or you even mention that you need
something that might appear a bit silly
or or not very good and immediately we
just Define ourselves oh you know but I
did this but I had a good reason there
was this and there was that guy who did
that and I thought that so we do that
constantly and if we couldn't do that
uh so for instance when you're driving
uh you can't talk to the other drivers
and I think that's one of the main
factors in road rage is that someone
can't explain you know I cut you off but
I'm really in a hurry for that so like
when you talk and talk to people you can
explain things and usually it smoothies
things over very well but as soon as as
soon as you remove that ability to
justify yourself uh things go south
pretty pretty quickly
so that'll be one of the reasons why we
have reason uh and the other would would
relate with with um communication
in the sense that when people talk to
each other it's great and it's super
useful
but if there is a disagreement
what do you do so you know if you tell
me something and I I think that it's
false
unless I really trust you a lot and I'm
just going to change my mind but that's
kind of risky because you know maybe
you're mistaken maybe you want to
mislead me even
but if you can give you a reason then I
can decide well we can maybe it has good
grants for for building this uh maybe it
doesn't but I can I can you know make a
more informed decision about whether I
should trust you or not and I can
provide you reasons and so in a context
in which individuals do communicate
then it starts making sense when people
when people communicate a lot and rely
on communication a lot the way humans do
that it starts making sense to be able
to exchange reasons so that when we
disagree we can figure out who is the
most likely to be rights it does seem
slightly strange at first hearing to
imagine that reason came about for
primarily social reasons we tend to
think of reason as something that is
sort of objectively out there in the
world There are rules to being logical
or to updating our priors using basis
theorem Etc and this evolutionary story
of why it came about seems very
different but maybe it's compatible I
don't know what how does this relate to
ideas that that logic and reasoning are
out there in the world objectively
without even us constructing them so I'm
not going to go into kind of platonism
and whether you know my IDs exist in the
world because
um
what I want to point out is that
um for this whole thing to work
it has two leaders to more accurate
beliefs on the whole
so you know if the two of us when we
exchange reasons we exchange arguments
you know we disagree so we you know you
say this because of that I say you know
that because of something else
if on average the outcome of that
process uh was bad if on average we
ended up with worse IDs that we started
from if on average the guy who was wrong
ended up convincing the other one that
would be that would not be selected for
that would be bad and so that means that
even without following like the strict
precepts of you know
neurological validity or obey asianism
the intuitions people have about what is
a good reason or what is a bad reason
must somehow track what is actually true
because otherwise we would not be doing
it so it is social
but but we have to have kind of
epistemic benefits at the end of the day
otherwise it would not be worth it
okay so yeah for the purposes of this
conversation we're imagining that there
are things that are true and things that
are false yes
and however reason evolved it it needs
to bring us closer to truth most of the
time in order to be effective to truth
or to to things that are kind of you
know good for you Fitness more generally
I guess right and okay last question
about the evolution of it
I mean I think you said something about
this but I just want to get it super
clear in my own brain is there a single
kind of spark or phase transition or
shift in you know how thought works from
let's say other great apes to humans
that enables the whole constellation of
things that include social structures
reasoning language or did one of those
come first or were there multiple things
that appeared at the same time yeah I
mean I think the the most commonly
accepted Theory would be that it was a
succession of events that led there but
clearly they're related to each other
for instance you know in the example of
a reason we're discussing it is because
there is this this this space of
cooperation communication that it makes
sense to start developing reason
and and I think the same goes for for
the other so there must have been some
changes in the Ecology of you of kind of
our ancestors
that meant that it made more sense to
cooperate more once you start
cooperating more than than if you can
communicate better you're at a huge
advantage and then when you communicate
better you know you're even better if
you can reason with each other
so there's this kind of we don't know I
don't think there's an agreement over
what is the spark you know what is the
thing the the initial kind of ecological
change that made it uh that meant that
our ancestors started cooperating more
than other primates but once you're
going to start going that way you can
see how kind of when thing leads to the
other in a relatively natural manner but
they're still you know they still took
you know hundreds of thousands of Euros
if not millions of years probably
actually millions of years and it was
pretty Progressive we don't know exactly
how or when it happened because we know
so little about
about you know the species that preceded
us
um
but I mean you know we do know things
that people are for instance we know
that near International probably has
language that was as sophisticated as
ours and so that means that our common
ancestor and probably people about 300
000 years ago had about the same
cognitive capacities broadly that we
have right but before that if you look
at species before Homo sapiens uh it
becomes a bit trickier to infer exactly
what they were able to do okay very good
yeah well you know look there's there
needs to be some questions that we uh
will answer in the future
there's no shortage but okay I want to
um my job as the podcast host is to be a
tiny bit of a skeptic just to give you
the chance to you know push back so you
seem to be saying that in in some sense
reasoning evolved not to sit at home and
do math or logic but to persuade other
people that we were right to you know
ultimately as a rhetorical device and
but but you want to say that
nevertheless it does lead us closer to
the truth so did that I mean surely
there's some cases where the best
rhetorical devices are kind of
disengaged from the truth
yeah so
essentially we think of Reason has it
been two sides so on the one hand we use
reason to produce reasons and arguments
and justifications and when we do that
we are quite thoroughly biased so
you know and that makes sense so if my
goal is to convince you have something
I should have my side bias or a
confirmation bias in the sense that if I
start giving you arguments uh you know
against my view and for your view I'm
not going to convince you obviously so I
need if my goal is to convince you I
need to find Arguments for my view and
against yours and this is indeed what
people overwhelmingly do whether they
want to do it or not they're just how
reason works
but there's this other side of Reason
which is how we evaluate arguments and
when someone else gives you an argument
then your incentives are very different
your incentives are are much closer to
the kind of normative uh goal of having
an objective objectively true answer in
the sense that you know someone is
giving you a reason you disagree with
them your goal is to know well should I
change my mind
and at the end of at the end of the day
you're going to benefit if the belief
says that you form are more accurate or
if the decisions that you make are kind
of more beneficial to you and so when we
evaluate reasons
the the bias is that kind of plague the
production of reasons completely
disappear so we are quite objective
we're able both to uh to to realize that
bad arguments are bad but also to
realize that good arguments are good
even if they challenge our points of
view and so and then so when the two of
them work together so when you're
talking to someone and people are being
of good faith because you know maybe you
have some common incentive you know like
playing poker or something like that
um
then it works well so you know I'm going
to be my ass when I give you reasons you
will evaluate them quite objectively if
you find that they're crap people tell
me and you will tell me why and I can
you know give you other reasons you will
give me your reasons you'll be biased in
doing so but I will evaluate them
objectively and that's what makes the
whole thing work is this kind of back
and forth between the production of
reasons which is biased and the
evaluation of other people's reasons
which is much more objective and exigent
it's pretty easy to come up with
examples of people who are relatively
reasonable and smart and yet they have
made up their minds about some things
and it's almost impossible to imagine
them persuading each other and I I
include myself in this on issues from
the existence of God to the right
interpretation quantum mechanics right
like I'm too old to really imagine that
I will have a dramatic change of my mind
uh on these things is is that is that
feature of how we think and reason
explicable in terms of this framework I
would I would think so but not only
um
so clearly there are things for which uh
it would be hard to imagine that there
will be arguments that be sufficiently
strong like you know when it comes to
integration of quantum physics
you know maybe that could be you know I
think you're just thinking too much in
the actual real world but yeah it's
image information an alternative World
in which you know some new experimental
data comes up and and that completely
leads logically to you know to a change
in the framework I think you would
change your mind of course yeah
um so I think reason Works quite well on
its own the problem is that uh reason is
not by far the only cognitive mechanism
we have or we use and in many cases I
think what's going on is that there is
kind of interference from from other
cognitive mechanisms in particular
mechanisms related to our social lives
and in particular those that tell us
that if you change your mind you're
gonna look stupid
and so you know we we have we have
commitments to our views you know people
think of us as being you know like a
lefty or someone who has such and such
interpretation of quantum physics in
some cases
um
and and and you know and you know
rightly enough that if you were to
dramatically change your view uh people
might think well you know that's weird
why did you do that I can't really rely
on that person uh or you know maybe he
was wrong all along so you know maybe
he's not as competent as I thought he
was
and so we do have an incentive to some
extent to appear maybe more coherent
than we are and I think we can see that
and we can even fill it ourselves like
we've all been of bad face so you know
you're in an argument and you know the
other guy is making a good point but you
refuse to concede so you have reason
telling you actually that makes sense
yeah
mechanism telling you either no no no
this is nonsense
and and sometimes actually you can track
I mean at least you know kind of in our
pers you know experience I think you
know you have a discussion and you don't
budge but then a few days later like oh
yeah it kind of made sense you know when
you're in the public debate you don't
like if you don't you don't really
change your mind but in fact the reason
is kind of working behind the scene to
make you realize actually if some of
these arguments were pretty good
is it fair or unfair to say that we sort
of first come to our beliefs and then
use reason to justify them or we use
reason to come to our beliefs
so in the overwhelming majority of cases
we come to our beliefs through you know
everything else in your mind is designed
to you know are not everything many many
other cognitive mechanisms like
perception you know you open your eyes
you form a whole lot of beliefs about
you know the world around you you know
who is there what they're doing
etc etc
um or people you know give you testimony
you know I tell you my birthday then you
believe that my birthday is such and
such day
and so we form these beliefs and then
when these beliefs are contested when
people disagree with them then we come
up with reasons uh but there are cases
in which is the other way around and
these are the cases in which someone has
convinced you with a reason uh so you
know there are for instance you know as
an external psychologist we use this
little kind of toy problems you know
mathematical problems that are very
simple but very deceptive and most
people get them wrong but then when you
explain the correct answer to someone
they change their minds uh most people
change our mind early immediately and in
that case they have the correct answer
because they have accepted a good reason
so you know both happen but in the you
know the vast majority of cases people
come up with the belief and then they
when when the need to Rises they justify
it to others
you you emphasize the social aspect
enough that if I recall correctly you're
willing to say that if you were just by
yourself if you were an isolated person
there'd be no reason to use reason
well you know as humans we have it so
you know whatever someone else is going
to do with their brain when they're on
their own I don't know but but if we had
been a solitary species
or something uh I don't think we would
have had there would have been section
pressures for us to develop reason okay
but but then again I mean if you're in
solitary confinement I'm sure some
people will try using reason uh to
distract themselves
so it's it's interesting it's like a
spandrel in some sense
um the fact that we can
prove mathematical theorems we there's
no evolutionary pressure to prove
mathematical theorems but there's
evolutionary pressure to persuade our
fellow human beings and that led us to
develop a capacity that we now use to
prove mathematical theorems yes no no
exactly that's that's uh that's the
beauty of it in a way is that it's it's
it's uh it's an accident like the
disability and I mean reason is not the
only ability that we use for science but
it is clearly a crucial one
uh it did not evolve for that at all and
it's you know it's our great luck that
that that we can also use it to to you
know to prove mathematical theorems and
to develop you know physical theories
and and like that and presumably this
helps explain why our reason has uh
faults why we're subjective uh subject
to cognitive biases irrationalities of
various forms
he has no exactly I think one of the of
the great strengths of our of our theory
is that he explains this otherwise
extremely puzzling feature of of Reason
which is well attested and you know
countless psychology experiments which
is the confirmation bias of the myocyte
bias so it's something I was mentioning
earlier and the idea is very simple
whenever people have any kind of
preconceived nourishing they have some
some intrusion some idea about something
and they start reasoning about it
overwhelmingly they will find Arguments
for why they're correct
and that's you know irrespective of
whether they happen to be correct or not
they will just spontaneously think of
arguments where they're correct whether
it's about a logical problem or who
they're going to vote for what car
they're going to buy anything if you
have if you already start thinking well
this one is is the best option uh then
you will mostly find reasons for why
that's the case
the very very first podcast episode I
ever did was with Carol Taveras who is a
social psychologist and she related to
story you know other people's research
but and it's probably a famous example
in Psychology literature of this
doomsday cult that doing exactly when
the breakfast is going to happen social
psychologist yeah yeah and so it didn't
happen and they interviewed them
afterward and the evidence was
irrefutable because they said it was
absolutely the world's gonna end and it
didn't end but none of them said oh we
were wrong they all said well we just
prayed so hard and cared about it so
much that it we stopped it actually how
it was kind of split so so half of them
gave up on the cult
dug deeper and and you can see I think
some interpretation of that would be
that essentially
in your your mind your brain is
confusing the costs of different actions
so either you give up with the cult in
which case you have a benefit which is
well
you know uh clearly what they're saying
doesn't seem to make much sense and you
can you can maybe you know recreate or
rejoin kind of you know old friendships
and maybe a family that you might have
can abandon on the other side if you
stay with the cult then you you keep
this very close-knit group of friends
that you can rely on and the fact that I
actually you know we said the world was
going to end and it didn't end
it's not the end of the world if the
benefit you get from saying that is that
you you get to keep living with these
people who might be your only support
group at that stage I understand so in
even in the most hardcore sense it is
arguably not irrational to say those
things oh yeah no no I mean I think I
think it's really hard to show that
something is irrational and that it's
really important to distinguish
irrational from false I mean obviously
what they're saying is false okay but in
there are countless situations in which
saying or believing false things might
be perfectly rational
and this segues very nicely into this
idea that if we are so we we developed
reasons to sort of persuade our fellow
human beings and this gives us this
wonderful set of abilities but also sort
of an obvious set of exploits that are
available uh mistakes that we make so
does this make us susceptible to being
persuaded of false things by people who
are very good at such techniques I don't
think so because I think the the way
these mechanisms should work is they
should err on the side of caution so if
you don't really understand an argument
uh then you should just stay put and
stay with your prior belief and so the
person should not manage to change your
mind
so this anyway that's the beauty of the
mechanism is that it's it's not you know
it's not completely foolproof
but you know by default if it's if it's
a topic that you really care about
something that might impact you in your
daily life that you might pay you know
genuine cost if you get wrong
um then people really have to give you a
good argument for you to change your
mind otherwise you just you know you're
just gonna stick with your with your
prior beliefs I guess it makes sense
um the process of updating our beliefs
is an essentially conservative one we
don't want to make radical changes from
moment to moment well no but in that
context it's really important to
distinguish
um communication from from other
modalities so in particular from
perception so you know if if you believe
that your keys are in your pocket but
you see them on your desk blam
immediately you change your mind and you
accept that they're on your desk but if
you believe that yeah in your pockets
and that someone tells you oh actually I
saw them somewhere else maybe you're
mistaken maybe they lose why not my keys
so our minds process communicating
information very differently and the
reason is quite obvious is that in an
evolutionary context we can trust our
perception I mean obviously it's going
to make mistakes sometimes nothing is
perfect but it evolved so that you know
to help us uh form an accurate vision of
the world and and to behave adaptively
at it by contrast other people evolved
to serve their own interests that might
very well and that often do differ from
ours and so you can't just take someone
else's word for it even you know even
your kin even people who are close to
you their incentives are going to
diverge from you from yours to some
extent and so you always have this
filter that when it's communicated
information you know you need you need
proof you need good reasons to change
your mind whereas if it's perception by
default you're going to you know
perception is going to override memory
so I guess this feels like a mixed
message to me in the sense that we seem
to have examples where lots of people
believe false things and what you're
saying is not oh people generally
believe true things but the reason why
they're believing false things is not
because some very very persuasive uh
propagandist persuaded them it's because
they were kind of ready to believe these
all things yes no exactly and I think
you can see that because the type of
first the type of false things that
people believe are surprisingly
consistent across the world
um so you know people will have beliefs
in ancestors and ghosts and witches and
you know in some types of gods that you
find recurrence you know with a lot of
you know fascinating variation obviously
but but the Core Concepts tend to be
recurrent in just about any human
society
and if you think of what would be the
concepts that would be like if you were
someone who could just you know persuade
people at will you know why make them
believe that I mean you know there are
so many things that you could make them
believe that would be better for you
rather than them believing in ghost for
instance or in ancestors or whatever
that it's not you know it doesn't fit uh
with the idea that someone is just
influencing them in whatever way they
want it just people are are prone as
you're saying to have some beliefs and
it's going to be very easy for them to
grow up accepting these beliefs compared
to others and and that's that's the the
main reason why they have them you do
bring up a couple of fun examples of
exactly this one is the fund might not
be the right word one is the uh
skepticism about vaccines worldwide
which you say there's plenty of
skepticism out there but in different
parts of the world the reasons offered
for that skepticism are completely
incoherent from one to one yeah no
completely so
you know that we saw that again during
the obviously the the coverage um the
covet vaccine and the resistance in some
parts to the Kobe vaccine
is that people believe that people
become other people become vaccine
hesitant or anti-vaxx because they hear
that uh you know vaccines is going to
give you you know 5G something or
whatever else
um which sounds great but anyway uh
and in fact it's really the other way
around is that there is an audience for
search views uh because people have an
intuitive resistance to vaccination
and we can tell that because in every
country in the world there are some
people who are really anti-vax usually
they're very small portion of the
population there'll be some people who
are kind of vaccine hesitant one that's
for sure
um and that has been true from from the
very beginning of kind of enforced
vaccination and inoculation in the UK
and we don't have the same pattern of
kind of universal uh not in the sense
that everyone resists but in the sense
that everyone there are people who
resist for other types of Therapies
um
indeed I mean obviously there are some
therapies that don't work at all that
are very successful in many places
um and so in everywhere in the world you
have this every you know in some people
this residency vaccination and then it
is fed by many many different stories
you know it will give you autism it will
give you AIDS it will give you whatever
else
um that are kind of custom made to
appeal to to different cultures you know
what is the the prevalent theory that
culture at that moment that will be then
linked to vaccination but that does not
cause the fear in the first place
it seems like rationalization is much
more common than rationality is is one
motto from this yes so in most cases we
will come up you know as as you were
saying earlier we'll have a belief then
we'll rationalize it we'll justify to
others and it's it's rarer although it
does happen that we we get our minds
Changed by by other people's reasons and
the other example that that struck me
was the um studies of Nazi propaganda
there's this feeling that Nazi
propaganda was like hugely successful it
led to all these terrible things but
apparently the studies are bringing to
question whether or not they were really
changing people's minds
know exactly know that was first picked
up on by uh Jen Kershaw uh like a very
kind of extended historian one of the
main historians of the Third Reich who
is one of the first to really look at
not only what was the content of Neti
propaganda and there was so much of it
unfortunately but whether it worked and
his contention based on on you know his
broad knowledge of the data and also
kind of fascinatingly the Nazi they had
their their version of Canon Gallup they
wanted to know whether you know where
the German people were thinking so they
couldn't you know do a proper pull but
they had someone some people who were
tasked with figuring out what the German
people were thinking
propaganda
and with casual uh thought was that Neti
propaganda worked so to speak only when
people already believed what the
propaganda was saying and so
unfortunately in many places in Germany
uh Germans were quite anti-semitic
already and so in these places
um uh Nazi anti-semitic propaganda was
very successful at least in the sense of
being widely accepted and you know where
they spread
with the Nancy made many other efforts
like they wanted to persuade you know
Factory workers to give up communisms
they had no no like in that at all they
wanted to impose like wespread ethanasia
for the handicapped you know everybody
hated them for it they wanted the Nazis
to be liked and the Nazis were never
really liked in Germany they liked
Hitler but they the most energy
operatives were mostly kind of reviled
so
in many of France it was quite it was
quite uh kind of unsuccessful and more
recently there had been there has been
more um protective studies that have
managed to look at whether how effective
it had been the Nazi propaganda in
different ways and it really confirms
car shows a conclusion in the sense that
it seems to have made things worse
marginally in areas where people were
already very highly anti-Semitic but it
didn't have any effect or even backfired
in areas with with kind of low
anti-semitism
so if I'm trying to summarize this it
sounds like in these attempts at Mass
persuasion might work if what they're
really doing is just heightening beliefs
that are already felt what about when
people just have an empty spot where
that belief would be I mean can you just
go in there and create a belief yes so
but to come back to the first point
quickly
um propaganda can have many Insidious
effects even if it doesn't persuade
anybody so for instance the once the
German uh the Germans rightfully enough
sadly will realize that the government
was kind of backing them up in their
anti-Semitism and that if they engaged
in anti-semitic acts they would not be
persecuted you know prosecuted or
anything then you know obviously it
gives them free range to do whatever
awful thing they want to do
um even if that without changing their
beliefs about you know the Jewish people
but their change their beliefs about
what would happen to them if they if
they attack them it also creates this
kind of coordination points in which
people realize that actually wow I'm
surrounded by a lot of people who don't
like Jewish people either so you know
that gives you more strength and that
you know allows to to take you know more
action so all of these things are
horrible but they're not persuasion in
the basic sense like these people are
already anti-semitic they just the
propaganda allows them to realize that
the government that other people also
are
and obviously the same thing can happen
for good things like you know people can
realize actually there are more people
who care about they claim it than I
thought so it's not it doesn't have to
be negative but but it's not going to
share perspiration
um
and now I forgot where was the other
point when you don't when you don't have
a pre-existing strong belief can uh yeah
so it can it can it can
um so that's what can a political sense
is called non-attitudes and so you know
if you ask me uh do you have a take on
on a commercial treaty between France
and Germany that I've never heard about
you know I might try to tell you
something because I want to I want you
to think I'm knowledgeable but
essentially I have no idea what's going
on and for these kind of attitudes
people are quite easily influenced by
people they already trust so you know in
the US if I'm a big you know Bernie
Sanders fan and I know he has that
opinion on that specific topic then it
will tend to agree with him on that but
that only works as you're saying for
things in which we have an empty slot
and we don't have any intuition and we
don't believe it will affect us in any
way
so
so it's not it's completely rational at
the individual level to do this because
if you trust a guy because you know you
think he has served your your cause and
your voice for for decades then it makes
sense to believe in him on some issue
you have nothing to you know nothing
about
but it can still be problematic at the
collective level in the sense that
public opinion does influence policy and
so if a lot of people believe something
then it might actually influence
policies so people don't they're not
careful individually because it you know
it doesn't make sense for them to be
really careful about these ideas but it
can still have some some kind of social
impact
and yet
um there's a lot of effort put into
trying to persuade people at Large Scale
right whether it's political campaigns
or advertising or entertainment or what
have you is that just a waste of time or
are they just do they do they secretly
Intuit what you've already said that
they can sort of heighten beliefs that
are already there if done effectively
I think it's it's plausible that some of
it is a waste of money especially in the
case of advertising uh there was a very
good book suggesting that the you know
if advertisers realize how little
advertising Works online you know Google
and Facebook and all of them are going
to crumble and the whole internet as we
know it is we kind of threatened uh so
we but there's again working and working
are different things so I think what is
clear is that it is not the case that
people's preferences are deeply shaped
by advertising so we can say well people
are buying you know SUVs because of
advertising people some people like big
powerful cards that's just something
that is there
um but if you're an advertising agency
so if you're most people you know
whether you buy one SUV or a very
similar model from another brand you
know it makes very little difference to
you so it you know the fact that you
want to buy an SUV is because of your
preferences that you had before but from
the point of view of the brand whether
you pick their SUV or some other SUV
makes obviously all the difference sure
and so advertising can still work
doesn't make you not in making you buy
an SUV instead of a mini but in making
you buy maybe you know one SUV compared
to another model that is you know pretty
much the same so it's not changing your
mind it's just shifting your brand
awareness and uh yeah the margin a
little bit and even these effects are
relatively small right but you know that
can be a win for advertisers uh even if
you know it doesn't imply that that
people have really changed their minds
dramatically I should mention that
studies show that advertising on
podcasts is very effective
I mean actually there's this brilliant
anecdote by speaking of podcasts on the
Freakonomics podcast my um Steve Levitt
in which you recount it being hired as a
consultant by a big company that sold
hardware tools okay and
um and he was asking them so they're
asking him to look into you know the
advertising uh they're doing and they're
spending like dozens of millions of
dollars a year so there's big companies
like big spending you think well they're
going to think really carefully about
what they're doing
in which he reported is that essentially
they had no idea what they were doing
and they say look you know we know
advertising works because every year
before Father's Day and before Christmas
we do have a lot of advertising and then
people buy more Tools in fact well you
know maybe it's Father's Day so yeah
anyway and so yeah no it's a lot of
money might be wasted in that debate
yeah
well so
what tell tell us more a little bit
about what are the
I guess I'm thinking that this is sort
of medical analogy what are the forms of
resistance or uh inoculation we have
against being gullible to Crazy claims
whether it's at a personal level or a
mass level like is there is there
something that the individual listeners
can say oh yes if I
sharpen my ability at this I will become
less gullible so on the whole I mean I'm
sure there are ways of achieving that
but my my take on the on on this is that
people are already too conservative if
anything so the problem is not that
people accept things too easily
is that they reject things too easily
and so if you take like you know vaccine
hesitant work and anti-backs people I
think they can go in with this
preconception against vaccination which
is in some extent understandable you
know you're injecting something into
someone who's healthy et cetera et
cetera so and it's you know it's
mistaken but you can see the intrusion I
think
um so they go in with this
and then the issue is not that they
gullibly accept messages because they
already have that Viewpoint the problem
is that they reject uh the medical
consensus on vaccination
and I think for most of us we should
think about more is how can I open my
mind more you know what is the
information out there maybe from people
who come from different disciplines
different you know political parties you
know different countries whatever uh
different you know ethnic background you
know whatever that what are these people
saying that I might be missing out on
because I don't trust them because they
don't listen to them enough I think
that's a much more important question
than what are the messages that now am
being influenced by in a bad way
well that's very interesting
um it would suggest that rather than
valorizing skeptical thinking although
there's a place for that clearly
um but open-mindedness or willingness to
contemplate ideas you don't already have
is maybe even more valuable if you want
to reach new insights you don't already
have oh yeah no bye bye I would say by
orders with my initiate because by
default we tend to be quite conservative
and and so you know we evolved in a in
an environment there was obviously
vastly different from the when we were
in now and so we for ancestors you know
they knew just about everybody they
would ever talk to in their lives and
they could discuss things at length and
so if someone has a good idea you know
you know that they whether they're
knowledgeable in that area or not you
can you know whether you can trust them
or not you can you can talk about it and
exchange arguments so it's quite likely
that you'll end up changing your mind if
it's warranted whereas nowadays
um you're confronted with a lot of
information that you don't really know
the source you don't know if you can
trust them or not you don't know if
they're competent you don't you can't
talk to them and so as a result you just
you're not persuaded by them uh even if
if sometimes you should
okay actually this is yeah that's very
interesting
um so just to put bring it down to earth
and see if I get it right there's this
feeling that you know there's a bunch of
people out there who believe in Bigfoot
let's say and the criticism of those
people is that they're not skeptical
enough they're too open to this crazy
idea and what you're saying is uh
actually like any reasonable person has
heard plenty of other people say no
Bigfoot does not exist you know there's
no evidence for it and their actual
problem is not that they're too
credulous and they they're willing to
they're they're too they're not
skeptical enough about Bigfoot is that
they're too skeptical about the very
good reasons given why Bigfoot does not
exist exactly I think it's very very
rare to find someone who has not you
know in our societies who hasn't been
exposed to the to you know correct
versions or better versions of their IDs
and it has kind of refused them
and so if you start with the idea so
bigquery is a bit of a you know not that
many people believe in Bigfoot but then
again if you look at things aren't
vastly more common like you know vaccine
you know vaccine hesitancy or conspiracy
theories and and that people seem to
have a knack for kind of intuitively you
know in every culture people have you
know some good portion of the population
will have those beliefs
um
then the issue is that they fail to
correct themselves or they felt they
failed to accept to be connected by
others
um and I think that's that's the that's
the main problem we have here and it
really does sound like part of that main
problem is our fondness for whatever set
of priors or folk beliefs that we start
with or or even just wishful thinking I
guess
yeah I mean some of it is is you know
some some you know personal attachment I
guess but as as we mentioned earlier in
the case of that of that group of that
uh that had predicted the end of the
world uh that have been fortunately
proven wrong
um a lot of it is social so if you're a
conspiracy theorists like someone who's
quite you know into that movement if
you're like a big q and person that's a
lot of who you are that's a lot of of
the time you spend that's a lot of the
people you know
as abandoning that belief uh or that set
of beliefs would entail typically large
social costs in terms of you know
friendships that are broken and you know
you lose your hobby uh so people
identity control are not being
necessarily rational even though at the
social level the costs can be can can be
significant
well I guess there's a down-to-earth set
of questions here
um in the modern world it does seem to
be that there's lots of people who
believe lots of false things uh I guess
you've given us some framework for
understanding why that is is there is
there some suggestions for how to fight
it how to fix it uh to get against
misinformation Etc yeah so
usually my they said the solutions I
would I would advocate for the most are
things that are hard to do and that are
very systemic so for instance if you
take something like conspiracy theories
in every country in the world there are
conspiracy theories and you have you
know 10 15 20 of the population who will
tend to believe many of these things
um
as far as I can tell the only thing that
really matters at that scale is how how
good of a government you have so if your
government is very trustworthy and not
corrupt there will be fewer conspiracy
theories
so that doesn't mean that the conspiracy
so if you're in a country like you know
Pakistan or that that has a pretty not
very functional government and a lot of
actual conspiracies yeah it doesn't mean
that the conspiracy people believe are
actual conspiracies but you're in this
mindset of it's plausible that there
will be conspiracies so if you follow
your look you know it's the government
the U.S government that goes 911 it's
plausible because you know the Pakistani
Amendment does bad stuff yeah and and so
and so that's the thing if you want to
know if you want people to accept
vaccination more then to some extent uh
pharmaceutical pharmaceutical companies
can also clean up their act even more
and you know be even more transparent
and and be even more trustworthy it's
not going to solve everything but if you
really look at the aggregate level the
only thing that is going to meaningfully
lower the rates of things like
conspiracy theory is if people have no
grounds like fewer grants for believing
in these things it's not going to bring
them to zero they'll be kind of
paranoid-ish people everywhere
but it's going and we know it's going to
lower the aggregate level
so that does seem to suggest that
a government that might be tempted by
paternalistically keeping people from
the truth would be better off just
letting people in on the truth because
that would in the long term increase
people's trust in government and then
the people will be more willing to
believe them when it's very important
yes no no completely I mean that's
that's uh there will be the conclusion I
mean obviously you know trustworthiness
of The Government Can can take many form
and have many forms that have many many
causes but but transparency would
clearly be important yeah I don't know
you know how much you're into it living
in a different country and so forth but
of course we have uh radical
polarization here in the United States a
part of which is an epistemic
polarization people just believe very
very different things and it to the
point where it's hard to find a common
ground to imagine changing people's
minds uh let me not put words in your
mouth is there is there some way to deal
with this partisan uh epistemic
polarization that is suggested by this
way of thinking so first of all uh as
far as I've kept tabs on that on that
literature
um there is some like an ideological or
kind of epistemic polarization it's not
as bad as people tend to think so if you
look at pools regarding you know what
you think about gun control or abortion
or whatever
um the average Republican or Democrat
tends to be much closer to each other
than people think um it seems as if the
thing that is really clearly growing a
lot in the US at the moment is effective
polarization where people from both
parties increasingly dislike each other
yeah okay and interestingly this is
likely due to a mix of factors one of
them is
people are increasingly ideologically
coherent so increasingly like if you
look at you know 30 40 50 years ago
right you could be you know a Democrat
but you were you know program and you
were in anti-taxes or whatever it was
kind of all over the place whereas
nowadays increasingly people are maybe
more informed about politics they follow
they know more about politics and that
means that if you're Democrats or vice
versa Republican you feel more compelled
to agree with most of the of the you
know the points that the Democrats um
defend and then obviously then it means
that if if you know that someone is a
Democrat then you can infer that you
know if you're a republican yourself
that you're going to disagree with them
on many many things which gives you some
grounds for not liking them so much
um so it so yeah so
but then again I mean it seems as if
and the solutions aren't going to be
easy because we know it's not it's not
just social media for instance social
media can amplify the problem
partly because it tends to show you the
most extreme versions of the of the
other side
so some people believe that social media
creates issues because it it cuts you
off from seeing what's on the other side
of the political Spectrum but that
doesn't seem to be the case if anything
you are more exposed to kind of
cross-cutting information from from the
other side of the spectrum on social
media than in real life
but the type of information you tends to
be you tend to be exposed to on social
media is some of the most extreme
information so if you're a Democrat you
might only encounter you know some
Republicans saying some extremely silly
offensive thing because that's the thing
that will create outrage and be
retreated
and so you have people have increasingly
this distorted view of of the other side
and that is kind of what is driving
ideological polarization but as a caveat
to that obviously social media has been
rising in just about every country but
there hasn't been a rise in effective
polarization everywhere
so clearly affective polarization social
media on its own is not sufficient to
generate kind of by by magic or by
necessity
um effective polarization and and some
people suspect that in the US is still
kind of kind of rational tensions in
another you know historical problems
that still can enhance the U.S and that
may be Amplified by social media but
it's not it's not just social media
I'm wondering it's interesting it's not
the same everywhere there it is not also
just the US right it is also true in
some other places so it's not something
appeared in between but I'm wondering
how much of it is just I talked to Ezra
Klein about polarization here in the
United States and part of it is just
sort of a game theoretic calculation on
the part of the politicians that
undermining trust in the other side
helps them win and and maybe this
points to a fundamental instability of
democracies in a world where technology
lets people get messages out so
effectively
um yeah I know that's possible that's
you know that's quite pessimistic but um
you know
I don't know it's possible on the whole
I tend to be quite uh skeptical of
overly pessimistic stances about the
effect of New Media apparently because
you know across history for every new
type of media whether it's print or
whatever else there has been a lot of
people saying it's gonna be the end of
the world and in every case it has made
things better so you know I want to
believe that this series is going to is
going to continue
um
but clearly you know modern societies
have issues that uh
uh I mean
I think people tend to underestimate the
the potential of social media so for
instance there's a lot of talk about the
effects of kind of tick tock on
teenagers and teenagers or only
consuming talk and it's you know it's
terrible
but in a way I mean before social media
there is literally no way of reaching to
teenagers almost I mean they don't read
the New York Times they talk to their
friends they you know whereas now you do
have something that possibly you know
the government or you know other
organizations can use to to convey
messages to to teenagers at a large
scale that was not possible before so
there are dangerous but there are also a
lot of opportunities that that
increasingly hopefully people will tap
for the best
yeah no I mean my inclination is always
like you to try to be optimistic about
these things especially because like you
say we've really come a long way and
been able to do some great things with
seeing things that seemed scary uh but
also it is kind of our job if we are in
a new situation does that raise new
dangers right for the Old Reliable forms
of government and social organizations
that we've been relying on for so long
it does I mean if anything it's probably
it kind of it speeds things up in a way
so it makes social change happen faster
so it's not clear
um it dramatically changes the direction
in which is going to happen but you can
see how it can happen faster because
just people communicate better they can
coordinate more easily
um but fundamentally people's
preferences are are not that different
so yeah okay good so and I do actually
like to conclude each podcast on a more
or less optimistic note I mean is there
is there some optimistic message here
about how given that we did develop
reasoning
um for social reasons and that we're
less gullible than some people might
have us believe can we become even more
reasonable
by finding people we trust and letting
them criticize us or something like that
you know is there some uh yeah I know
completely no no I mean you know the
ideal context for us to reason well is
to find people uh you know who we
respect and and you know before of good
faith and and but still we have to
disagree about something like if you
agree about everything uh things are
gonna make are gonna become worse so we
have to be we have to be careful about
that maybe you can when kind of
optimistic messages
to travel is that that's something we've
touched upon already is that we probably
don't don't trust other people enough uh
so it's likely that on the whole we tend
to be a bit too conservative
and that's
there are some some nice ideas by by
this Japanese uh researchers Reserve
unfortunately passed away a few years
ago to show your magishi and his ideas
that trust is is something like other
skills and the more you try trusting
people the better you get a trusted
thing at figuring out who you should
trust which makes sense in a way because
if you never trust anybody
you never know whether you should have
trusted them so you know if you ask me
on your podcast and I say oh no I don't
trust that guy I never know whether I'm
going to have a good good time or not
whereas if I do trust you well sometimes
I'll get burned sometimes you know it'll
be great but at least I'll know whether
I can trust you maybe I can extrapolate
that to other people
so as long as the stakes aren't massive
there is a there is a big benefit in
just trusting people because then you
learn more about you know whom to trust
and whom not to trust whereas if you if
you're too conservative then you just
stay stuck in your little bubble and you
never you know you miss out on all these
amazing opportunities that yet other
people can provide you I think I'm
violating my own rule here by letting my
little pessimistic side come out but
whenever I hear suggestions like you
know yes we should trust other people
more I I suspect that a lot of people
hear that as yes other people should
trust me more I completely agree with
that
this kind of bias is that they they see
biases in others but but not in
themselves
but uh yeah I mean in particular I think
that's particularly true there it's been
shown in experiments when you have kind
of groups of people that you might
Harbor some kind of prejudice against
um you know if and then if the stakes
are in high I'm not advising that you
put your head your your life in the
hands of someone you've never met or
anything like that obviously but if
these things are in very high uh
I think so I think in a lot of cases
what stops us from trusting people is
not so much the the thing that we may
lose a bit of time or a little bit of
money is that we're afraid we're gonna
look silly if we get yeah and I think
it's worth you know overcoming that uh
to to say well okay if I lose you know
then again a bit of time or money it's
not the end of the world maybe a little
bit silly but at the end of the day I'll
be I'll be the winner we have to make
some mistakes if we're going to make
progress exactly that's very optimistic
advice I'm very happy to end there so
you go Mercier thanks so much for being
on the mindscape podcast
thanks so much Sean
[Music]